welcome to this video playing act or
lack corner our cooler sorry and
terribly screwing this up let's see what
is doing d4s plate let's see it may be
an Enzo I'll do something else though
this time not the same issue all the
time 93 is also interesting with g3 oh
ok yeah there's also Queen d3m just
trying to remember the theory check
check yeah this is a known line leading
to a position that is somewhere between
equal equal and slightly better for wide
for my book project i have i have
selected a similar similar line but not
exactly this one I went with 96 and only
then 94 which is comparable but not
identical ok of course if I get some
time here just one or two moves like
castles and rook to e1 or 94 I'm
excellent there that's exactly what I
was about to say black must be quick
here cannot afford to lose any more time
so and he went to get active in the
center not sure maybe after death maybe
I should have gone to to d3 immediately
not to e3 and then lower that but ok it
still seems like a decent
III before I guess hard to play without
that a 3d form and then possibly c5a
night see form okay yeah he's so playing
this very aggressively but it's not
clear if it helps him so much let's say
'if oh I get this check in yeah he's not
like doing for that um here 94 96 it
would be very nice but not see if I he
has if already and that's not so great
Quincy to and maybe then d3 even
hmm yeah I need to move the Queen away
no one no not a good spot on these three
now away some exposed to Temple gains a
divine light c2 now well I think I can
do it yeah t3 now i can i can take take
9421 take quinta exam looks a bit shaky
Abbott and this I didn't consider let's
look strange I thought I mean I have
this b5 muth and if he goes d 3 2 uses
some pawn math in the center well my
bishop ball will get alive oh yes I
didn't think of it all
rabbit is it any good I go f3 and I'm
threatening to take now and if he takes
takes f4 is the threat now now this is
this is not so great for black my bishop
is getting alive and it's just the far
better piece in this position yeah that
that's an idea a good good idea takes
Knight f4 okay I don't know mm maybe
King f2 tom okay very tricky the ship f1
on hand yeah well should I just break it
open yeah let's do that the nidus is at
the moment in preventing this the sound
I look to be activated with the rook h1
and stuff 93 is always the problem yeah
be sure that one is not really helping
maybe maybe still Ricky one rupee form
could still be the right move he goes d
3 I have rooks III and getting the poor
now
and n2e form
taking their for porn and d4 so I try to
put pressure on both points to win one
of them okay all night if for now or
this Knight g4 check
I can play Bishop c4 actually it's not
so bad why didn't I decide didn't think
of really because I forgot about the
move but ok this should be ok i think
takes on f4 is the threat and if he goes
king at 50 King g5 rookie one setting up
a pin ok here i guess here i am d tu
roop t1 is nothing terrible happening
out I don't see anything terrible
happening but you never know for the
moment of threatening a form
check you must go back otherwise they
would regenerate your morning campuses
this will be tough to win check
this way to at least keep a pawn yeah
well justice is a draw of course but
maybe I can do something Cham it's very
passive huh Jeb just said wrong nothing
to do rah our third game drawn yeah I
should have won that somehow i know i
don't know why i don't know how exactly
but this was certainly a win somewhere i
came i looked his amnesia yeah I came
offering the rook trade is probably bad
route de semanas looked his seven is
stronger is it maybe they aren't that
strong on the seventh yeah probably i
should have done that i am
underestimated his counter play really
when I exchanged looks it was the kind
of keep it simple attitude but um its
release it really keeps itself as it is
it is really simple because it's a
simple raw he gets some gets all the
pawns is really nothing nothing to do i
hear c6
and then a six maybe yeah but I still
believe it's a draw okay thanks for
watching